before we start do you have insurance
what your coverage good like you have
dental oh haha is there a hospital
nearby is it like too far about like 25
minutes I'd
say I just slapped you are you all right
what so you like to fight you ever win
no one ever wins a
fight
[Music]
[Applause]
this ain't the holiday and pal all right
I'm
moving friend of mine suggested I come
talk to you I own a roadh housee out in
the Florida
Keys lately it's been attracting the
wrong
clientele I can pay you good money judge
him by your car you need that well I
like my car think about
it
I know who you are Elwood dalon Big
B that guy's got a knife under his shirt
he just take a big step back and pop me
in the face you can do
it tell me about this bouncing yeah all
nice like he's Mr Roger or something but
then he'll haul
off really interesting guy
overall BR wants to take the Roadhouse
away from me he wants to build some
Resort
I should warn you people have a certain
way of getting things done around
here hey fellas looks like you're having
a smacky
night I got a tip for you don't let no
one get this close come
on let me get you know threaten me tell
me to get out of
town I get the impression that you can't
be threatened
once KNX is on the job it's over
baby it takes a lot to get me angry but
when I
am I just can't let
go people seem a little aggressive
around
here is that one a friend of yours no I
just broke his
arm